out of the car you know stop go back
where he told you come on I'm not
playing go back so much for joining me
the film I hate to say it was a great
film cuz it ripped my heart out and like
made me emotional and made me cry but it
was so very well done and I think you
both kind of play two sides of social
activism the person who gets inspired by
it and unfortunately the people that are
victim of its ramifications so talk to
me about having to represent those two
kind of sides of social activism I think
something about it felt kind of meta
because we're making this film about
police brutality about a character who
is standing up to it
and through the film we're hoping to
protest police brutality so in that way
you know I felt like both of those
experiences were feeding into each other
just working on this film defending its
integrity protecting the character and
the authenticity of the character so
that we can make something that speaks
to these issues with authenticity and
then playing this character who has to
find her voice I mean I felt like very
often inspired by star and I felt very
grateful to be able to play her because
I learned so much from her well for me
I've kind of just been saying it uh over
the weekend a lot just coming to the
realization I think understanding that I
was just I was put there to just be a
vessel just to speak and just to help
bring some type of peace or some type of
understanding some type of beginning of
restorations to the families that have
gone through that exact same thing or
the brothers that have lost brothers or
whichever whatever type of loss you've
had I think for me it was just
understanding that moving myself out of
the way and just just being open garden
Heights mama and daddy says our life is
here because our people are here for
those of you that are parents or
soon-to-be parents I just want to ask
you is this now seeing the hate you give
seeing films about activism is
and where you feel like you have to have
a dialogue with your kids about it now
that was before waiting for the movie
and so what what have you changed now do
you think about having your
conversations and kids about activism
and just like social engagement and just
how they've kind of changed the way that
they view the world as far as like
getting on social media and talking
about these issues oh well I'm gonna
make sure that my kids have those
conversations and communicate those
issues everywhere but social media I
think the best contact is human contact
I think social media has led us to a
point to where we can't relate to people
and that's why people lash out because
we don't know how to communicate I mean
I absolutely empower my and my kids with
information and empowering them with the
knowledge of self and you know wisdom
and understanding about who they are
where they come from and then it's gonna
be up to them to make the decision as to
what kind of activists they choose to be
you know I just that's all you can do
and I think that's again that's what
math and Lisa did as parents they just
empowered and their children gave them
knowledge and then whatever comes forth
whatever they grow into that's who they
are I mean I don't have kids but I would
imagine that you know with my nieces I
would probably caution them against
social media I would definitely want
them to create their own way of thinking
their own mind and and try to you know
empower them with knowledge you know
with education that they could make
their own kind of informed decisions
from them sort of reading with somebody
who doesn't really know that much about
anything is saying you know there's no
responsibility and there's no
responsibility
today garden Heights is real aches after
the shooting of a 17 year old black
teenager by a white police officer we
live in a complicated world it doesn't
seem that complicated to me this is a
young adult book adaptation and I feel
there's always gonna be things that
don't translate from the page to the
screen and vice versa if someone asked
you Angie what was something that was
added to the film that you felt was
richer and like you enjoyed more and
then George what was an aspect of the
book that you kind of regretted that you
couldn't include in the film but you
still really liked it
you know one aspect that I really wished
I would have included in the book is how
the film really focuses on the theme of
thug life through Sukanya it slipped my
mind I didn't even think about it but
the film did it in such a powerful way I
really do I called my editor and I was
like so I know we're going into another
printing can I go at that is no but that
was so well done and is so powerful and
it really really brings the theme in
that people can understand it and they
can visualize it and feel it through
this kid so that's definitely love that
well I think it was for us it was great
as we were having that conversation
early on so we're always saying no Angie
what if we take this character away and
then put a little bit of that in seven
reduce a couple things so we had there
that conversation if I was making a
three-hour movie maybe I would say some
of the stuff that maybe in the communal
the community there's a lot of
characters I was around around math
store but I felt like we grabbed we had
all that with the guys that we had you
know you know at Rubens barbeque or mr.
Lewis barbershop those guys are around I
think it's so powerful that the families
have this conflict so they move out of
the neighborhood or should they stay
mm-hmm and we see how that's resolved so
I feel very happy where we came up with
the high school is where you go to get
junk high or pregnant we don't go there
Williamson is another world so when I'm
here I'm starvation - oh those kids'll
it basically Williamson star doesn't
give anyone a reason to call her ghetto
and I hate myself for doing it tell me
about how you guys kind of came to the
material if you got it after you found
out about the movie or before
well I received the script before
reading the book and I read the script
and I was just so moved by the story
that I had to pick up the book and also
I just knew that I just really really
desperately really wanted to be a part
of the project so I'm really happy that
I ended up going my way yes I didn't I
didn't know about the book at all
actually and then I I I did a self tape
in my book then so I went right to bars
a novel get up and when I picked it up a
girl was like I love this book and I was
like just I'm gonna play Kenya in a
movie she was so excited yeah I didn't
know about the book but I read the
script and him immediately fell in love
with it and then we don't - read the
book I read the book before I read the
script and obviously I loved the
character Hayley and I wanted to play
her so bad yeah so I mean once once I
was able to like finally be a part of it
I was like oh my gosh this is so crazy
yeah because all of you guys are great
but I wanted to say that you're an
amazing actress cuz I hated you so much
um speaking of which I feel like this
film sort of embodies activism for young
folks like there's an entire generation
of folks coming up where activism is
kind of like they're coming of age and
this kind of book in this film I think
will represent that for you guys who are
you know just you know so far removed
from that but what was a film or a book
that kind of defined your coming-of-age
like when you were 16 what was something
that you saw we were like this was my
16th role life the I saw a documentary
called the Black Power mixtape and I
learned about Stokely Carmichael and
and I just I didn't go natural in my
hair yet cuz I was scared you know as
for black women and girls it's a really
tough thing and when I saw her rocking
her afro and empowered me to have my own
yeah spider-man spider-man actually one
book that was really impactful for me
just in my life was the alchemist by
Poliquin and Piper I remember reading
that book when I also things like
sixteen or seventeen or something like
that and yeah it just it changed my life
you know that book is really big on
manifestation and kind of like just
willing something into existence and
Rick putting it in the universe yeah
yeah you know putting it into the
universe the universe will conspire to
hell yeah it was just like that was
crazy yeah that was just crazy Dan
everyone has their own personal legend
yeah yeah I would say the same that just
reminded me that book to me was
literally changed my life absolute crazy
I think for me I'm like I honestly music
was a was a huge influence for me and
like what you say like finding your
voice I think there was a lot of artists
which obviously the the film is so
heavily inspired by Tupac and I don't
think the film could have been aired the
book obviously could've been created
without the influence of music so I
think then that there are so many
artists with so many different messages
it's hard to pick one but I think that
that was a huge part of finding my own
voice as a young girl
what is something a piece of music a
book a movie from your coming-of-age oh
man tribe called quest's midnight
Marauder honestly it's a pox trapped you
know they got me trapped in his prison
of seclusion happiness living on the
streets is of delusion even a smooth
criminal one day must get caught
shut up a shot down from the bullet that
he bought you don't I mean it's just
that just takes me back and into that
eye that idea is that you know there's
nowhere safe oh wow that's a great
question do the right thing for sure
really define me
my understanding of film the power of
film what it can do what it can make you
feel also beloved by Toni Morrison is
one of my favorite but to talk about all
the time because it really was defining
for me and it's still continued to be
another one would be love Simon awesome
well in in hate you give to the
characters in Simon and thug are related
yeah okay when you ready to talk you
talk I never let nobody make you be
quiet I mean you start by asking
you